winter is coming and there is no justice
in the world but what we make high
Sparrow this is an interesting episode
it's one I liked quite a bit now we are
kind of running into what I've said the
last couple of episodes which is that
not a ton of really active stuff happens
but new wheels are turning in addition
to things moving forward and stuff that
had gotten going already so there's
still a good feeling of forward momentum
even though there isn't a ton of boom
impactful stuff actually going on so
while it's not quite as forcefully
moving ahead of season four was we're
not in quite the holding pattern problem
that the start of season three was I
suppose we can start at King's Landing
where we actually have another wedding
now the show treats it very much like a
shotgun wedding in bow out done and
moves on very quickly which is good
given the show's track record with
weddings and the power dynamic continues
to shift at King's Landing and we get to
spend a bit more time with Toman than I
think we ever have up to this point toen
himself continues to be a bit of a
nonentity there isn't a lot to him but i
am still liking his stuff because we get
to see Marjorie do what she does best
which is to manipulate someone into
doing what she wants so well that they
think it's their own idea I mean she is
just so good at this I just I do not get
tired of seeing it happen seriously
continues to appear to be losing her
support structure and does not seem to
have a lot of friends left and I'm gonna
be interested to see what lengths she's
gonna be prepared to go to the more she
gets backed into a corner because I
remember Jamie really grown me in a
character when he got backed into a
corner mainly back in season 3 so I'm
gonna be interested to see what she will
now do we also get a bit of a better
look at the sparrows which comes back to
that character who I talked about before
who came back and you know whole new
look so we've got sort of this surge
another religious group you know very
back to basics very simple only the
simplest things in life and we meet the
high Sparrow played by jonathan pryce
who i am loving because jonathan pryce
is a very affable actor you sort of
immediately kind of warmed to him you
like him he just seems nice but I can
already see sort of the strands and the
mentality about this guy that's going to
make him a problem for certain
characters and I I'm immediately
intrigued by him not so much that he's
overly deep or hard to read but just
house a character like that being
inserted into this world particularly in
King's Landing all places how that's
going to disrupt a lot of stuff we get
kind of an extended scene with Brienne
of Tarth and Podrick and I really i'm
loving the pairing of them more and more
the more time we spend with them I mean
it was kind of a nice odd-couple pairing
right off the bat but it's just
deepening and it's becoming more
enjoyable to watch and Brienne of Tarth
has it has a great sort of monologue
speech that she gives that just gives
great terrific insight into her
character into her history and it does
what this show does very well which is
to encapsulate so much of a character
into a story about their own pass and
not just about what happens but the way
that they tell it we touch base at
Winterfell for the first time in a long
time of course now it's under control of
the Bolton's roussanne Ramsay which
means reek formerly Theon Greyjoy's
kicking around as well now Theon i'm
still gonna call on that Theon I'm
really gonna be interested in because
being back in Winterfell you're starting
to see like little glimmers of maybe
there's still something of who he used
to be somewhere in the back under this
completely beaten down animal that he is
at this point now I'll be curious to see
how and if that pays off Sansa kind of
running neutral for me again she has
some moments in terms of how she behaves
that I'm coming and that's a little bit
like the sansa that I got very tired of
but as has happened before she is
continuing to be put in very interesting
situations and I just want those
interesting situations to seep in and
inform the character a little bit more
than they have in the past up at the
wall we spend a bit time they're not
much really happens and then not much
that you couldn't have guests coming off
the last episode anyway it works fine
there's nothing wrong with it but that
no surprises what's going
on up there if the wheels are spinning
and moving forward is just I know
exactly where it's going so it feels
like it's not going anywhere as well as
the one other thing that felt a little
bit like it was just okay can we get
somewhere with this was with Vera
cinterion because they've just been
traveling in their continuing to travel
and it's like yet could you get
somewhere could something happen well
you know thankfully something does
actually happen and but I'm glad to
because I was really really starting to
be like oh please don't make me an orbit
earring and Vera thankfully we get a
nice sort of ending moment with that
that I'll be interested to see how that
plays out as well so this wasn't
necessarily an episode they got me
pumped for too much but is there's a lot
that am I oh yeah I'm seeing a lot of
potential in in what happened here and I
don't even want to say groundwork cuz
there is forward momentum on a number of
plot points it's still all set up but
it's all interesting center oh you know
the one thing I forgot to talk about is
Arya in the house of black and white
which has a good feel for it she's there
she's sort of getting accommodated is
this mysterious kind of place training
ish sort of scenario and I'm okay with
that for this episode I just hope she's
not stuck in that for too long now
having not read the books I don't know
if this is the case I feel like the
people behind the show really kind of in
a tough place with this season cuz what
it feels like is they had to pull
material from a book where not a lot
happens and a lot of stuff just gets
prepped for what will happen later but
they have to still find a way to make
that interesting if that is the case
they're actually doing quite a good job
because I'm I'm not bored I'm interested
in what's going on it's just I am sort
of getting to that part like cool this
is all good set up some of the things
being set up need to start actually
happening soon that that would be good
oh one last complete side note we get a
glimpse just one scene very good of a
red priestess which i think is basically
the same thing that lady Melisandre is
and plagued by this actress whose name
I'm not gonna try and say because I'm
gonna butcher it but I spotted her
recognized her immediately because she
was one of my favorite things about the
movie The Wolverine and I hope to god
she comes back is there sort of a
character who was seen briefly who we
haven't seen for a long time where was a
toss away character who you would like
to see come back who potentially could
who is
dead if there's any character like that
for you why don't you drop something
down in the comments and we'll talk
about it and until next time this
council is adjourned